the microsoft family recently exploded
in size and now has 22 developers under
its roof
that's a lot which means there's a lot
of games in production and it's going to
be tough to keep track of them all
but we got you covered hey this is kurt
let's go over who is a part of the xbox
family
and what they got cooking in the kitchen
for this generation of gaming
343 industries aka the halo studio
since bungie parted ways with microsoft
to pursue a new destiny back in 2007
343 industries was put in place to take
over the halo franchise
halo infinite is up next sometime in
2021
alpha dog games alpha dog games is a
mobile game developer responsible for
wraith born
and montro city rampage we don't know
what they're working on next nor
do we know whether or not it'll be a
mobile game or something for consoles
we'll just have to wait and see
arcane studios the folks responsible for
dishonored
and prey currently they're working on
death loop which is coming into
and the ps5
okay so microsoft acquired arcane after
death loops exclusivity
for the ps5 was announced and microsoft
is honoring that deal for now neither
microsoft nor
arcane have confirmed anything yet but
it's speculated that death loop will
find its way on xbox consoles eventually
meanwhile arcane is hiring for an
unannounced game
please let it be dishonored three cool
thanks alright see ya the coalition
aka the gears of war studio gears 6
hasn't been announced yet but i'd be
damned that they didn't have it cooking
because 5 ended with one hell of a
cliffhanger
in the meantime gears 5 is getting
updates for the xbox series consoles
with
story dlc on the way and other updates
like a new game plus
also the coalition in collaboration with
studio splash damage
developed gears tactics which is out now
on pc
and is coming to xbox one and xbox
series consoles
compulsion games responsible for
contrast and we happy few
it's currently working on a new game set
in a new universe but
that's all we know for now bethesda
games studios what did these
folks work on again oh right elder
scrolls and uh
something called fall out
just kidding currently bgs is working on
star field a completely new franchise
and elder scrolls six we don't know when
those games are coming out or
whether they'll be xbox exclusives but
what we do know
is they will be coming to xbox game pass
on day one
uh whatever that will be double fine
production the studio behind psychonauts
through a legend and broken age just to
name
a few is currently developing
psychonauts 2 for xbox one
xbox series consoles as well as the ps4
it will be coming out sometime in 2021
it's software the mastermind of the fps
genre and creator of franchises such as
doom
wolfenstein quake and rage is currently
working on its latest released
doom eternal giving it a facelift for
next-gen gaming porting it to switch and
working on its two-part expansion
ancient gods
the initiative described as microsoft's
quadruple
a studio this is a new one made up of
talent from naughty dog bungie and
crystal dynamics and we have no idea
what it's doing but xbox daddy x phil
spencer suggests the team is working on
one of xbox's legacy ips
the rumor mill online says the studio is
rebooting the classic
xbox franchise perfect dark but my
money's on blinks
in exile entertainment with wasteland 2
and 3 under its belt
inexile is the classic rpg devs of
xbox's family and what is it working on
next well
you guessed it we don't know but the
studio said it might be a while until
its next game is announced
machine games the wolfenstein studio the
swedish team
took over the franchise and revitalized
it with 2014's the wolfenstein new order
following up with wolfenstein 2
the new colossus and its spin-offs the
old blood and youngblood
it hasn't announced what's next but i'm
desperately itching for another
installment in the mainline wolfenstein
series because bj blaskowitz is a hunk
of a man and i love him
mojang studios the minecraft studio most
recently a code developed minecraft
dungeons
with double 11 and continues to support
the ever evolving original game
but interestingly we still haven't got
official word on next-gen ports but
i mean come on it's on everything so i'm
sure we're good
right yeah yeah ninja theory which is
responsible for hellblade
senwa's sacrificed and most recently
bleeding edge
next up it's got a few things cooking
including senua's saga hellblade 2 and
project mara an experimental horror
experience
obsidian entertainment another rpg
powerhouse and the maker of the outer
worlds
not to be confused with wilds at the
moment the studio has its fingers and
all sorts of pies including grounded
outer worlds dlc and avowed a new first
person rpg
also obsidian made fallout new vegas and
since obsidian and bethesda are now
practically step siblings it's about
time we get another one of those going
so
get on with it playground games what
could once be viewed as the forza
horizon only studio is now working on
reviving the classic
xbox rpg series fable rare
rare continues to ride the wave with its
games as a service sea of thieves is
also working on the upcoming adventure
game ever wild
a fantasy game with magic majestic
animals and robes
roundhouse studios back in 2019
developer human head studios shut its
doors
but only days later its entire staff was
purchased by bethesda forming
roundhouse studios that said we don't
know what the team is working on
but it has a history with the original
2006 prey
a franchise taken over by arcane so it
all ties together one way or another
most importantly these are the same
developers that brought us the quiet man
and while i love pray i really hope xbox
is funding the quiet man
too the quieter man please tango
gameworks founded by resident evil
director shinji mikami tango gameworks
did the evil within one
and two at the moment it's working on
its first person action horror game
ghostwire tokyo
but like death loop it is coming to pc
and just the ps5 a decision made prior
to the microsoft acquisition
no word on coming to xbox just yet but
only the future will tell
turn 10 studios the other half of the
forza franchise
turn 10 studios has been developing
forza motorsport game since 2005.
and you wouldn't guess what it's working
on next yeah it's uh it's forza
motorsport it's gonna be the eighth
entry and it's currently in early
development
undead labs living right up to its name
making games about the undead with save
decay 1
and 2. this crew is working on a third
entry in the state of decay series
worlds edge aka the age of empires
studio world's edge was founded in 2019
to oversee the franchise and is
currently working on age of empires
4 which doesn't have a release date yet
zenimax
online studios cinemax online studios is
responsible for the elder scrolls online
and supporting bethesda game studios and
creating
fallout 76 back in 2019 it did announce
it was working on commander keen
a mobile game but from the looks of it
has been canned
since with that in mind we don't
actually know if they're working on
anything new
or just continue to support elder
scrolls online and fallout 76
hey you still with me if so thanks for
coming by
and i hope this was informative to you
now there's still plenty of exclusives
we didn't touch on in this video as
they're being made by third-party devs
like
blooper teams the medium or ebb software
scored but if you'd like
you can check out a video on the 9
biggest games coming to the xbox series
consoles
in 2021 and beyond by persia
link in the description below for more
on the past present and future of gaming
keep your eyes on gamespot and while
you're at it
check out generation next it's the show
about next generation consoles
alright thanks again and here's to the
quiet man 2.
see you later
[Music]
you